Here we are on the set of The Changeling.
This is Victor LaValle, the author of The Changeling.
And this is Kelly Marcel, the showrunner and creator of The
Changeling show.
Welcome to the Elk Hotel. This is the hotel of one of our
episodes.
Yes, it’s about a character named Lillian, Apollo’s mother, as she goes through her own night.
It’s like a dark night of the soul.
We’d love to show you around the lobby and the hotel.
In our show, we have Easter eggs.
Here’s one, this sign is signed by management, Lester. Lester Cohen is the production designer, and he is the mastermind behind this amazing, amazing set.
Yes.
And if we come over here, we will see another wonderful Easter egg which is this ship, which is called a Sloop.
If you’ve read the book and are a fan of the book, then you
already know how important this will be.
One other detail that we’ve been talking about today is how
much we love the wallpaper in this lobby.
And actually as we go through the hotel, you’re gonna see that Lester has chosen very solid colors for each section because it’s a very dreamlike episode.
Well why don’t you let us show you the rest of the hotel?
Yeah.
The other thing that’s interesting about the Elk Hotel is this whole episode is not in the book, this is something that came about from Kelly and I talking.
So, it’s not in the book, but really slides nicely into the world of our show.
But this hotel really existed, this is actually the color that the walls were.
Very nightmarish.
This is patient zero’s room, so Lester’s removed the two and the zero.
When you watch the episode, this room will completely
transform.
This episode is about people who have found themselves feeling discarded or forgotten, and all of them help each other through the experience.
As Lillian goes through this episode, she starts to remember
places and people from her life.
And we get to see her memories, like this.
This is one of Lillian’s memories.
Not one of the great memories.
No.
You will see some graffiti and this table top will magically change
by the end of this episode.
And feature carvings that you’ve seen on the first page of Victor’s book.
Tell me your life’s voyage.
And I will tell you who you are.